في زياره مفاجئه بايدن يتجول في شوارع
كياف عالم تركي يحذر من التسرع في بدء
اعاده الاعمار وماسك يواجهه تسع دعوا
قضائيه بسبب تويتر هذه الاخبار وغيرها
ننقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
في زياره مفاجئه لم يعلن عنها من قبل
ظهر الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يتجول مع
نظيره الاوكراني في شوارع العاصمه
الاوكرانيه
عن مساعده اضافيه بقيمه نصف مليار دولار
لاوكرانيا مؤكدا نعمل الولايات المتحده
الثابت لكاف في مواجهه روسيا وان الاخيره
ارادت ازاله اوكرانيا من الخارطه الا انها
لا تزال صامته
رغم تشرد مئات الالاف من السكان نتيجه
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا حذر عالم تركي من
التسرع من بدء عمليه اعاده الاعمال وبناء
المنشات الخرسانيه ما لم تستوفي شروطا
معينه عالم زلازل ناجي جرار نوه الى توابع
الهزات الارتداديه على الخرسانه المصبوبه
حديثا حيث يمكن ان تسبب شروخا صغيره
وتشققات فيها مشددا على استخدام الخرسانه
المسلحه مسبقه الصب والمعدم منذ فتره او
التيس لحين توقف توابع الزلازل
دعاوى قضائيه بالجمله يواجهها الملياردير
الامريكي ايلون ماسك منذ ان تولى زمام
الامور في شركه تويتر لاسيما تلك المطالبه
بتسديد فواتير غير مدفوعه ملاك عقارات تضم
مكاتب للشركه واستشاريون وموردون تقدموا
بطلبات سداد متاخره على تويتر في تسع
دعاوى قضائيه على الاقل فيما بلغت القيمه
الاجماليه لمبالغ الشكاوى اكثر من 14
مليون دولار بالاضافه الى الفوائد عليها
الى البرازيل حيث تسببت الامطار الغزيره
فيضانات وانهيارات ارضيه خلفت سته وثلاثين
قتيلا على الاقل في ولايه
اضافه الى دمار واسع في مناطق عده عدد من
المدن البرازيليه الى الغاء احتفالات
الكرنفال الثانويه حيث تكافح فرق الانقاذ
للعثور على المفقودين والجرحى واشخاص تخشى
وفاتهم تحت الانقاض فيما افادت حكومه
ولايه سان باولو في بيان بان هطول الامطار
في المنطقه تجاوز 600 مليمتر في يوم واحد
وهي واحده من اعلى مناسيب سقوط الامطار
على الاطلاق في البرازيل في مثل هذه
الفتره القصيره
في مشهد اعاد الى الاذهان الحادثه المؤسف
الذي تعرض له الطفل المغربي ريان توفي طفل
مصري يبلغ من العمر 6 سنوات بعد سقوفه في
احد المصارف الصرف الصحي بقريه بدمياط
شمال مصر فرق الانقاذ تمكنت من انتشار
الطفل بعد ثمانيه ساعات من الجهود المضنيه
استخدمت فيها معدات ثقيله للحفر في الموقع
بالاضافه الى الات لسحب المياه الا ان
الطفله فارق الحياه قبل وصوله الى
المستشفى